King Arthur he's been in the gazillion
movies not the least of which is a new
one that is coming out directed by mr.
guy really got to talk with Charlie
Hunnam who's from son as a narky stars
in this movie check this out King Arthur
yeah I'm being directed by guy ritchie
don't get more of that like i can
honestly say i never had more fun he
gets very involved the rehearsal
consists of standing there watching one
guy actual of the that's really and he
has a nice tendency to heckle like hey
[ __ ] can you do that again and just
try to look like a movie star you know
there's like that was always what the
movie I want to see now is not the guy
ritchie movie but the making of the guy
was absolutely a camera on the action
your kid from Newcastle who's that means
something to play King Arthur if you're
from the aisle like was it daunting at
first if I had allowed myself to think
about it I would have completely freaked
myself out but listen people have been
telling this story for 1,500 years and
it's cuz it's really you ain't gonna
record you know Sam you got Ritchie
can't freaking arthur wright was one of
my favorite films growing up the john
bowman Excalibur cal it was like
instrumental in and my childhood so
thought about Excalibur like every day I
tried to think about it never I actually
didn't even go back had been several
years since I watched the film just felt
like I wanted it to be completely
original in our version of it